hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i'm muscleleads and today we're going to
be talking about your credit report how
to make sure you have a really good
credit score also uh the phone company
ee
muscle's feeling pretty mad today and
how to manage your money to make sure
you can get the best finance the best
mortgages as property investors is
really important that you're ahead on
your finances your money management your
credit scores russell has recently found
out that his credit score is terrible
no more mortgages no more finance
everybody's disowning him his credit is
he's ruined
that's not true okay that's not that's a
little bit of an exaggeration however
your credit has been hit recently which
has really bothered you what's happening
yeah so you obviously i was around your
house and you heard me getting quite
angry on the on the russell doesn't get
angry very often but he was quite angry
all right so let me explain the
situation i'll give you a little bit
back story and then we can talk about
the lessons from it and how it all works
so um i've always had excellent credit
rating um i've never missed a payment
i've never had any issues with my credit
and my experian credit score has always
been nine nine nine uh occasionally i
might go on it might have dropped
slightly to nine nine seven but then
soon it goes back up against nine nine
nine right okay and i've always been
quite proud of my credit score
and how much credit i can get anyway
i um looked on my experian credit score
today this morning and i was disgusted
and shocked to say that i was no longer
in the green i wasn't even in the yellow
i was in the orange oh not the orange
and i was dangerously close to the red
literally a smidgen smidgen above the
right so so if you've got a really good
credit you're green
you're normally always green i'm green
green's good
yellow is
fair fair uh orange is fair to pour and
red is terrible so you were in the
orange so i was incorrect in my
introduction you were not in the red
you're in the orange in the orange but
still orange you're gonna you're gonna
struggle to get mortgages i was in port
affair that's terrible that is terrible
i was i was disgusted and shocked and
outraged yes
by this so
you think to have a fair to poor credit
maybe you'd have to of um not paid some
bills you might have a ccj county court
judgment against you maybe you um
regularly borrow money can't pay it back
and that's why your credit is like that
how did your credit go from so wonderful
and clean and spotless to so fair to
poor yeah um so quickly so what happened
was um having looked through everything
was good on my report apart from one
thing it said that i had a um i'd missed
a payment
didn't tell me what for and i'd have my
account closed for whatever it was that
i missed a payment for a few months ago
so i rang experian and i was like i'm
baffled by this i understand i haven't
missed a pen as far as i'm aware could
you please tell me who it is and they
told me it was ee
now to put me in context i've been an ee
customer for 13 years
yeah
so all of our
business our whole business is an
e-customer so all our staff that have um
uh workforce are with ee so we spend
quite a lot of money and have them for
quite a long time with ee my wife's 3d
imovie so all about all of our mobile
phones everything's all through the
company yeah through samuel is limited
we've got a lot of phones so how would
that affect your personal credit and how
did how did we have an ee bill that was
on page how did this happen so what
they're saying is
six years ago
apparently i took out i don't even i i'm
not even sure this is true this is what
they're saying six years ago i took out
a dongle
with ea i remember you doing that there
you do
i just got dongle with ea and when we
moved everything across and migrated
across to a business account the dongle
for some reason unknown to um me and
unknown to ea didn't
get transferred across so the dongle
stayed in my name right so i've been
paying for this dongle for the last
four years wasn't there two dongles
it was two dongles yeah and you'd be
paying 40 pounds each has 80 pounds so
i'm already thinking you'd be paying 80
pounds a month from your personal
account for the last four years for a
dongle that you've not even had access
to
correct which is annoying a lot of
people would be furious about that that
works out to about 4 000 pounds yeah a
lot of people would say i can't believe
i've paid 4 000 pounds for a product
that i've not been using this is
outrageous why would they not have not
written to me how could this have
possibly happened however the four
thousand pounds was actually the least
of your worries yeah i'm not really
bothered about the four thousand pound
because that's been and gone and it
hasn't affected someone affect me i know
the question isn't that we need to draw
a lesson from this how on earth would
you not have noticed paying 80 pounds a
month for the last four years do you not
go through your uh statements and check
what you're paying and how's that happen
because i will flick through the
statements
every now and again i'll do a checkup on
it and
i think i've just seen ee i'm so used to
seeing because i paid for it for my
personal account for so long having an e
i just see here i get my phone and i
didn't think
oh hold on a second the phone's getting
paid for by the business you just missed
it and you're quite particular on the
business bank you know you go through
the business bank every day yeah i'm a
lot i'm a lot more focused on the
business back than i am on my personal
bank the personal stuff
sorts out so yeah all allen's fault
that's all anna's fault is what you're
saying here so just so you know anna
this is your fault she doesn't even know
about this yet but it's just anna's
fault okay so then what happened
um so
uh where do i get to in the story so um
you'll be playing this thing
so i was like look i don't i don't
remember taking out a dongle i haven't
got a domino
dongle
so what every now and again another
thing that i'll do on my bank account is
i'll go through dire debits that i no
longer use
and i'll
scrap them off so you scrapped off this
direct debit for something you hadn't
been using was four or five years that
old however as it happens you are
technically still in contract well i'm
not in contract they're saying i wasn't
in contract but it was on rolling
monthly
okay and so you cancelled it yeah you
owe them 80 quid apparently yeah and as
a result of that they've put in this
default thing against you yeah you've
got an outstanding order of 80 pounds so
you ring up ee and you say let me pay
the 80 pound and they go no problem well
here's the thing right i knew because
from speaking to experience said i said
to experian i was like look this is
obviously some sort of mistake and i
said well ring ee if it is a mistake
ee can get taken off and it will be as
if it never happens and your credit
score goes back to nine nine seven or
nine nine nine or nine nine nine however
if you did default on the payment and
they and they think that you did then
what will happen is e will say hey he's
now satisfied this
it will go up a bit but it will damage
my credit it will always be for six
years like getting like losing your
license for six years i'm going to have
on my
thing yes i default on a payment i did
pay eventually so you might be in the
800s so it will damage me like a yellowy
green i might be in yellow or something
that's surely that's not that bad if
you're in the yellowy green you can
still get mortgages yeah it's it's not
that bad am i i have just moved house so
technically i'm not on the electoral i
have applied but it takes about six
weeks so i'm also being damaged by that
as well right now there's a few there's
a few things conspiring against me right
but i am so happy here's the thing right
lessons from this maybe you've had
situations similar where you've had a a
phone bill where you've you thought you
cancelled it but you didn't or you
didn't know you had it you've canceled
the direct debit that then said oh
default and you've had a knock in your
credit report and it affects you and it
means you can't then get mortgages as
easily or you can but you have to pay a
higher rate because you're limited to
the lenders that you can use um so
really this is the story that you've
heard but i want to just draw a few
lessons from this i've got to the first
lesson is to diligently check through
your bank statements every month not
just your business bank but also your
personal bank to make sure you're not
paying for stuff because that was the
first mistake of 4 000 pound mistake
just because you didn't check through
vigorously enough to make sure that i
think i think that's a pretty good
lesson definitely this is something that
we we talk about yeah all the time so
yeah 100
go through check your direct debits make
sure you're not paying for anything that
you're not using or any like imax or
anything like that oh yeah yeah i i
remember that actually what happened
briefly briefly similar similar type of
story so samuel um went to uh get an
imac um i don't have a credit card or
something with me now his credit card so
he basically i think he had like 30 days
to pay off and if he didn't pay it off
it went it was go it was he used my car
details so i would pay for it every
month if he didn't pay it for the 30
years he was like don't worry bro i'll
pay for it in 30 days i don't remember
this happening man i won't forget this
is about 10 years ago by the way it's a
long time maybe 12.
yes yeah it is a very long time ago you
were probably about 19 yeah i'd guess
right so um
i put it in my name anyway and
about a year later i looked on i was
like hey hey again my bad i should have
took them all i think it was about two
three years later it was definitely i'm
not trying myself but bad enough this
four year one
it was about a week later no it was a
little while i can't remember how long
it was about three years i noticed i've
been paying for his imac now for however
long and it was it wasn't cheap either
it was about it added up to about two
grand two grand or something and he rang
me up and he was like i demand you pay
me two thousand pounds today and get
this
dude you owe me two grand it's like what
i was like i've been paying for your i'm
at you mother for the last two years
so so basically the the lesson is to
make sure once a month at the at the the
the least you should go through your
statement and just make sure that
because there's so many things you can
pay for like gym memberships you can
forget about um little uh i don't know i
mean
there was a i won't say who it is but
there was one man who was paying for a
date and a dating subscription every
month and he forgot about it and i went
through his bank statement i was like
hey you're paying for a dating
subscription you are now married what
the heck you know it means like oh yeah
the marriage
you've forgotten all about it so go
through your bank statements and make
sure that if there's anything there that
you are
paying that you're not aware of make
sure you get it cancelled but
don't can't sit down with your bank
well no
because if you can't go over your back i
used to have the attitude of
if i'm paying for stuff
oh i just can't stay on my bank and if
if it's important they'll come looking
for me they sometimes don't
they still don't he didn't for me do you
know what that they're excusing so i
said to them guys i've i have like a
paying customer of yours paying for
other stuff you my number is with you
why didn't you not call me or whatever
and they were like oh because of covid
we've stopped making outbound calls oh
right because of course kovid means that
we can't call anybody anymore and they
said we did text the number that was on
farm but that number was a dongle that's
not a number so they text my dongle
their proper screws i don't even know so
cancel things from your bank if you if
you don't know what they are but make
sure before you cancel it don't cancel
it with the direct debit with your bank
cancel it with the actual um
the actual company in question so that
it doesn't do this problem second lesson
um
cancel your direct debits second second
lesson i know go on make sure you're
constantly checking your credit report
thank god you you checked yeah because
you're about to buy property next month
yeah you're buying a nice nice house
next month as a as a service combination
well that's what that's that is
why i checked right so i'll send them
over a credit report right so make sure
you regularly check check in your credit
report you can do this on places like
experian or you can do this on credit
karma check your credit report once or
twice uh you know a month maybe maybe
that's a bit too many times every few
months if you remember they'll tell you
i i sometimes different stages of being
a member of experian paying 14.99 and
now i think what's the point and i can't
solve i'll just go on and check every
now and again but if you are remember
14.99 yeah they'll tell you if it dips
or whatever yes i would suggest pay the
14.99 next lesson is if you do have any
defaults against you you are quite
demanding on speaking to the manager and
then the manager of the manager because
they were trying to fob you off they
were saying just pay the eight quid and
more satisfied and you were saying i
don't want you to satisfy it i want you
to take it off right what happened so i
said i'm not i'm not bothered about the
money i'm not saying i want my i'm not
saying i want the money about i have to
pay the 80 quid i have to pay 180 quid
right now what i want is i want you to
put it down as a mistake because if they
put it down as a mistake it will take it
off
experian i don't want it to go down as
just satisfied i want it taken off
because it is a mistake and i i i blame
uh it's partly my it is partly my fault
but i think it's part of their fault
because they didn't get in touch with me
they didn't contact me they didn't check
the most up-to-date address they had
they used the old address for that sim
yeah it's like come on guys give me give
me a break here so i i want to take it
off and i want my 999 listen if i can't
i might have to settle for satisfying it
and going for 800 or 700 or whatever by
the way your credit's going to be good
but it's going to it
might not be excellent again for a
little while but might be not an
excellent for six years
no it will be six years it stays on i
had a situation very similar with ee
where they did something similar to me i
satisfied it it didn't go down as a
mistake i went down satisfied yeah and
within about six twelve months it went
back to excellent now my credit score is
nine eight nine
okay so you'll be okay
i hope you enjoyed these lessons i hope
you enjoyed the story and we'll look
forward to speaking to you guys real
soon thanks so much russell would like
to make it clear that his credit is now
back to normal perfect thanks to ee for
rectifying the situation and i hope this
video helped
[Music]
you